what matters is not necessarily what are
the best returns that you can earn this
year that's what everyone chases but
that's not what matters what matters is
what are the best returns that you can
sustain for the longest period of
[Music]
time um let's just get right into it
Morgan what's going on man I'm happy
you're here I'm happy to be here thanks
for having me guys I read the book uh
your your first big hit psychology of
money a while ago was that four years
ago
about yep yeah and then this new one
just came out was it called same as ever
that's right yeah man uh and people I
the good reads reviews are higher on the
re most recent one I think than the
first one so congratulations no thanks
it's always it's always I think with all
books and all articles this probably
true for podcast too you really never
know what's going to work and what's not
and even I I've been a writer for 17
years and I still really don't know when
I publish something a blog or a book how
it's going to be received and maybe you
get a little a little bit better around
the edges but it's always like you just
have to birth into the world and then
and then just step back and watch it's
going to do whatever it's going to do
well you told me that the first version
of psychology of money you said that you
the first print run was I think 5,000
copies is that right so you guys you
thought you know 5,000 copies is is the
right amount you sold over four million
now so uh I think that that proves your
point of you don't really know till you
know uh but that is that number is kind
of amazing dude like over four million
books sold you are I don't know in the
top 0.01% or something of of authors you
know that I don't know how much you make
per book but I think that means you've
made like over $10 million as an author
on a successful book that's so hard to
do that's so rare and um you know
congrats to you for doing that thanks
Sean yeah I mean I was telling someone
the other day I think the closest
analogy to the book industry is probably
professional sports where
99.9% of high school basketball players
will never make the NBA I don't 99.999
whatever it is um but but then you have
a couple of of LeBron James and Michael
Jordans who go on to make a billion
dollars doing it and I I don't know this
to be 100% sure but adding it up in my
head I'm pretty sure there are more
billionaire authors than there are
billionaire athletes even in a world in
which 99.9% of books will sell you know
a couple thousand copies or or less if
that but then you have JK rling and Dave
plinky and James Patterson who who have
made over a billion dollars writing
books so it's just like extremely taal
driven in the success I want to ask you
about um one of your philosophies
because you're very interested to me you
have a philosophy it's very easy to sell
a philosophy of more right people do
that all the time and in fact even our
podcast I would say falls into the
bucket of the philosophy of more many
times when we say no small boy stuff
right we're saying think big play Big go
for it don't sit around and wait don't
don't be fearful right so more more
action more ambition more whatever
that's that's one philosophy a lot of
people fall into and some people go even
crazy right David gogins is like work
harder Gary ve Alex OSI these guys are
like just grind harder so people often
have the philosophy of more and some
people Marie condo and others have the
philosophy of way less you need less
minimalism um you know escapism just
become a a sort of a a Zen person go uh
whatever get those vans and just like
travel around the world right so it's
like um there's the philosophy of less
and you're in the middle which usually
is the dead zone for content uh you're
in the Middle where you're like no just
have enough right like moderation and I
can't believe you've got moderation to
sell I'm going to read you a quote and
then I want you to talk about this so he
said more than I want big returns I want
to be financially unbreakable if I'm
unbreakable I think I'll actually get
the biggest returns because I'll be able
to stick around long enough for the
compounding to work wonders I loved that
quote and I in general I find this
moderation thing interesting tell me
about that this is where like moderation
in finance is actually going to lead to
the biggest return returns because what
matters is not necessarily what are the
best returns that you can earn this year
that's what everyone chases but that's
not what matters what matters is what
are the best returns that you can
sustain for the longest period of time
and so this is why like on an annual
basis I am I strive for average returns
in my index funds by Design why do I do
it because that's going to give me the
endurance to hold them for 50 years and
if you can earn average returns for 50
years you're going to end up in the top
1% of all investors and you do it with
zero effort what's average uh in the in
the US Stock Market 6% reel six and a
half percent reel after inflation is
what's been if you can earn six and a
half percent returns after inflation for
50 years it's it I mean you can run the
calculations of it it it is it's going
to achieve every it's it's dynastic
wealth it'll make your great
grandchildren wealthy and so that's
there and you can do that with zero
effort now look past past performance
not indicative there's a nuclear war Etc
you can come up with all these scenarios
in which it's not going to work out you
can come up with scenarios in which
the economic conditions of the last 100
years are not going to replicate for the
next hundred years okay all those aside
earning average returns for an above
average period of time is way more
lucrative than trying to earn Superior
returns for a shorter period of time
like as always and I think it's so
counterintuitive the intuition for
everyone including educated professional
investors is how do I earn the highest
returns this year and like it's like of
course it's like how could that be wrong
it's like no if you're just average for
a long period of time you that's the
winner Pimco the big fun they had this
phrase that I love they called it
strategic mediocrity where in any given
year they were never going to be in the
top half against their peers but in
every decade they'd always be in the top
Des aisle because the peers that beat
them in any given year get washed out
and I think that I think it applies to a
lot of things it applies to a lot of
businesses it applies to relationships
and marriages of like you don't need to
be a superhero if you're just good for a
long period of time that's how
compounding Works its
magic our software is the worst have
have you heard of HubSpot see most crms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
that that thing you just said was
excellent I love that so you
said I want average returns for an above
average number of years rather than
Superior returns for a short period of
time um or you know I you know I in any
given year I'm not trying to be in the
top uh I'm trying to be you know sort of
50% but if I do that for 30 years I'll
be in the top 10 per. it's so true in
the kind of like slow and steady he wins
the race I think you had a stat that
like if Warren Buffett has I don't know
what it is like let's say $85 billion
dollars net worth like 81 billion of
those 85 came after his 65th birthday
right and I think you said something
like if if Warren had just retired when
he was 60 nobody would even talk about
him because the compound like obviously
he is a great investor of of course but
the whole secret what's literally 99% of
his wealth is that he's been a great
investor for 80 years that's why he
started investing when he was 11 and
he's 93 today still going as as as as
hard as ever and that's where all the
money comes from and yes like so his
average returns are are 20% per year
which which is phenomenal of course but
if you earn 20% per year for 20 years
it's it's really good if you're in 20% a
year for 40 years it's great if you're
ear in 20% a year for 80 years you're
worth $100 billion dollars like that
that that's where all the Returns come
from did you hear this Sam they're
giving that shirt away at Buffett's give
it away this year at the burar
conference just hard as ever still going
hard as
ever Is that real are you being serious
oh be hilarious dude but we joke about
war Buffett where he talks about uh you
know like uh well I forget the how he
phrases it but he talks about like the
the you know it's all about the future
it's all about the future and we were
like dude you're 93 like there is no
future like Bale and enjoy life and you
could argue like well he's he likes what
he does so you know it's cool he's
enjoying life but I've always like when
I think about long-term stuff I'll like
map out my life and I'm like man like if
I only live to be 80 I only have you
know uh 40 or something Summers left
like I don't I don't know if I want to
be I'm not willing to pay the price of
if that's what's considered great is
doing 30 or 20 20% returns for 80 years
I'm not willing to pay that price
because Life's too short and and when I
think about like what it requires to be
one of one to be one of the
greats that's what freaks me out is I
don't want to be that old and not have
enjoyed it you know that's why it's like
the converse to all this is Bill Perkins
book die with zero of like spend it
while you're here enjoy it while you're
here because when you're gone it's it's
pointless you know what I mean yeah yeah
now I think I think there's a couple I
think I I agree with every word you said
particularly for Ordinary People Like Us
I do think Buffett's DNA is just he gets
more pleasure from anything in life the
most pleasure he gets is from
compounding there's nothing that makes
him happier the other thing is even
though he's worth a hundred billion
dollars today he's given away a hundred
billion already and and with with with
the rest of his net worth effect you
know go into the bill Ming The Gates
Foundation I I imagine I don't know this
to be true but I imagine when he when he
lays in bed pondering his life he's like
I'm I I did I I I put my skill to use
and I'm going to give away a quarter of
a trillion dollars for the better of
society I was just in Omaha a couple
months ago where he's lived his entire
life and in Downtown Omaha one of the
tallest buildings says the Buffett
Center for Cancer Research or something
like that I imagine when he drives past
that and this is the building that he
drove past when he was five years old it
gives him a ridiculous amount of pride
and pleasure and so I actually think if
if he were on his deathbed tomorrow
Charlie Monger just died last month I
think he would look back and say like I
I I live the best life that I could have
it wasn't Perfect by any means but I I I
think there is a difference between the
Bill Perkins philosophy which is true
for 99% of people and then there's 1% of
people who actually get so much pleasure
out of compounding and thinking about
what that money is going to do to
society after they die dude there's this
crazy story about Buffett where his
daughter had just had a baby and she's
living in a [__] apartment and she and
uh a mutual friend of Warren and the
daughter went it was actually the CEO of
Washington Post went to the house and
was like Warren her kitchen sucks man
and so the daughter eventually goes to
Warren and goes hey can I get like a
$1,000 Loan in order to redo my kitchen
and he was like H just go to the bank
and uh so she eventually goes to the
bank and then a few months later uh the
the CEO of Washington Post goes back to
her house and the daughter's sitting in
bed but she has a really small TV where
she would sit and nurse her child in
front of and Washington Post lady goes
to Warren she goes Warren give her 500
bucks for a new TV man she could barely
see this TV and she's in bed like eight
hours a day can you just give her a new
TV and waren was like no compounding is
more important for that $500 TV I can't
I'm not going to to take the money out
and so Katherine uh the CEO of
Washington Post ended up buying her a
$500 TV but that's how like tight this
guy was about following his code which I
guess I appreciate that someone has a
code but that a that ain't my code wait
so Warren Buffett's just an [__] is
that the store is this a real story
because I hate War well yeah so War
Buffett gets he gets a pass for having
this all Shucks attitude but he's
definitely an [__] he's definitely an
[__] depending on how you Define
[__] I would Define him as a Wonder a
what do I say great men are also bad men
the way he handled his his family I
think was was not wonderful the way he
handled business associates was
wonderful so you know like it's there's
trade-offs to being great I think I
think as someone like I have so much
respect and admiration and reverence for
him but I would also put him in the
campus someone who was like I'm so glad
he exists but I don't think I would want
that for my own life which is not a
criticism against his life it's just
like to each their own and let's not
pretend that everyone should want the
life of the five standard deviation
success it's like there's a cost to all
of that I was just trying to imagine
like his daughter just like you know at
the bus stop trying to get a bus ride to
wherever she's going she looking up at
the Buffett cancer research center and
just being like God damn
it there's there's some other parts of
the story Buffett's uh first wife Susie
you know had uh billions of dollars of
her own and she was much more freeing
with with money so I think the the
buffet children and they did just fine
but yeah there's there's plenty of
stories about Warren he always described
he was like capital is my tool not going
to give like these are the tools of my
business this is how I make money I'm
not going to be willy-nilly with it and
even when Buffett was in his 20s when he
was a kid this is back in the 50s he was
already worth tens of millions of
dollars in the when that was real money
in the 50s and you could easily imagine
a world in which he's worth the
equivalent of a hundred million when
he's 30 years old or whatever it was and
everyone be like dude you need to give
all this away you're never going to be
able to spend this and his philosophy
was like his philosophy has always been
people in the future will be just as
needy as people are today day so if I
have an above aage ability to compound
it it actually makes sense for me to
hold on to this money for as long as I
can before I give it away which I think
is actually pretty rational you you said
a few things that I thought were um
contradictory in in different interviews
that I watched the and I think in the
book I forget I'm mixing up the book and
interviews that I watch but you talk
about financial goals and you're like I
don't look at I don't look at my
portfolio um I I think you said I don't
set goals or at least that's the vibe
that I got in an interview but then I've
also read a little bit where you do have
some type of goals um so for for
financial goals do you like have a
number in your oh sorry I remember what
it was you said whenever you hit your
goal you're always going to double it
therefore I don't have goals I think
that's what you said H it's such a the
the the reason it's hard for me to
answer that is I'm sure I've said things
that are contradictory because I like
everyone else it's like it depends
depends I'm not trying to call you out
no no no depends on I'm probably the the
mood that I'm in that day do I if I'm
sitting here today and I think do my
wife and I have financial goals not
really it's not like oh we're trying to
hit X and once we hit X we're going to
go by y like not really but I like
everyone else think about like oh if my
income stays the same we'll have this
much money what kind of life could we
live with that much money and one thing
too like we have two young kids and we
are pretty hellbent on not spoiling them
they live an amazing life and we live in
a great house they'll have a great
education they'll live the top 0 one% of
lives but we don't want to raise spoiled
little pricks and because of that we off
we often we have goals it's not like oh
how can we buy a a bigger house another
house nicer cars it's kind of like we
want to live a good but not extravagant
life because we don't want to spoil our
kids but like even that sometimes like I
can talk to other people who are like no
actually you can live the big high life
without spoiling your kids here's how to
do it so I I I feel like I say like I
think a lot of the contradictions come
from humility of just like I I I haven't
really figured it out yet for myself I
tend to not have goals for years I had a
goal of once my net worth is X I'm not
going to work much anymore because I
could easily live for the rest of my
life off of that net worth and I've
exceeded that number and I'm working I'm
working harder than ever but I don't I
don't regret that at all maybe that is
some version of moving the goalpost but
I think more of it is after I hit some
level of financial Independence after I
wrote books it was like okay I'm only
going to do the work that I enjoy now
and it's not really work it's just like
I really enjoy writing these books I
only speak at conferences that in cities
that I want to go to it doesn't feel
like work and I I don't think I really
understood that 10 years ago 10 years
ago work was by and large a means to an
ends I need to do this to feed my family
and now that I've reached kind of the
artistic level I'm like oh I want to
keep doing this forever and in that
world goals kind of go out the window
well we've like interviewed a bunch of I
mean we've had we have a bunch of
wealthy friends we've had a bunch of
people on here um you're like a
financial historian so you've like read
about all these people you also know a
lot of them and you've written about
them and you probably run in even a more
Elite Circle than we do but a question
that I've always wondered is is there a
threshold where I'm not going to worry
anymore so far I've not found that
threshold and we had Scott Galloway on
here recently and he was like I'm worth
like over 100 million liquid and I still
freak out have you found any type of
thresholds to where the average person
changes where they feel more relief I
don't know I don't know if the average
person I can tell you myself though that
number that I was talking about before
where for years it was like once I hit
this number I'm not going to work
anymore once I hit that number I still
can you say that number I I don't know I
don't know if I want to get too too into
DET maybe I'll tell you off camera it's
not it's not it's not a ridiculous at it
CU some people don't know how what how
should I think about what that number is
for me for example I was like oh if my
life annual burn rate was X and I wanted
a certain amount of money where you know
4% or 5% withdrawals of that uh would
mean I'm sort of setting neutral let's
assume I'm getting 6% real returns in
the market if I was to withdraw 4% out
to pay for lifestyle uh you know that
that number of the bank account is never
going to go down it's only going to go
up uh that's how
exactly how I calculated years ago Sean
you said yours was six million but if I
had to guess that has changed as you've
had a
family uh yeah no to be honest can I say
the honest answer is kind of ridiculous
sounding but like it's not that oh I had
kids and oh man I really underes these
diapers are expensive that's not
actually what happened I literally I
remember one day I was like okay so I've
done this I was like I kind of feel like
a guy who should have $100 million
and with I was like I think I'm I think
I'm worth that I think I should be like
you know I don't have to have it but
like if I didn't have it something would
feel a miss something would feel a
little wrong and uh then I was like okay
cool I think I should do that it didn't
become my like North Star of like I'm
gonna do this but what I did do was I
made sure that I would only um I would
only work on things that either I was
doing purely for the joy of it it it
didn't have to bring in any dollars or
if I was doing it because I thought it
was going to be financially rewarding
the financial reward had to be big
enough enough to make it to be like on
that path not a path not a smaller path
yeah do like I I came up with my number
exactly as you did Sean it was like if I
have a 4% withdrawal rate what is the
annual income that I know is going to be
like easily comfortably all that we're
ever going to want to spend and like I
just backed into the number and Sam to
answer your question of like once I hit
that level a I I kept working as I am
now and I don't think I was any happier
but I had a I have less Financial stress
less career stress because happiness
dude that's
happiness such a cop out I hate when
people say money doesn't make you
happier but it just gets rid of mddy
problems and I'm like yeah when I
worried about rent I was unhappy now I
don't I'm more happy I'm not necessarily
happy but I'm happier I I think like I
think we we probably agree this is like
arguing over the definition of words but
I would say there's a big difference
between happiness and a reduction of
anxiety I think those are very different
things happiness is is like you wake up
grinning ear to ear or it's like if
you're watching the funniest comedy
you've ever seen and you're just like
laughing on the floor that's a happy
moment but it's always fleeing but to me
the reduction of anxiety or contentment
that is something that money can buy and
that is worth chasing it's great so like
when people say money can't buy
happiness what they're implicitly saying
is it's not worth chasing I think it
absolutely is worth chasing but it's not
going to give you happiness per se it's
going to give you contentment and
reduction of anxiety which is wonderful
it's a massive increase in the quality
of your life but in my definition it's
not necessarily happiness but I I I I
feel like I hit that I feel like I'm my
my wife and I were talking about this
last night I feel like I'm in a better
mental state of like less anxiety than
I've had relative to you know five or 10
years ago which is great you know you
wrote the psychology of money um you've
studied this a lot I want to ask you
what what are the most what are the
biggest or maybe the most common leak
instead of uh most common I would say
the most
impactful uh psychological leak meaning
a way a TR a psychological trap or
mistake people make around money and I
want you to answer it for somebody who
is kind of on the come up so somebody
who isn't totally financially
independent yet and then for rich people
who still have a bunch of weird
psychology and Rel weird relationship
with money I want you to tell me what
you've seen or what you believe is kind
of maybe the biggest M psychological
mistake people have around money in each
of those buckets I think there's there's
two I'll start with one that's probably
the biggest which is social comparison
which is always Sean just mentioned you
know you want to be a guy you should be
a guy with $100 million I'm willing to
bet if you told 17-year-old sea that
figure you would faint but it doesn't
seem that ridiculous to you now because
I bet you know people who are worth $100
million and so who you compared yourself
to when you were 17 or 25 is different
now and I think there's no end to that
if and I hope you are worth a hundred
million doll someday I guarantee you
you're going to start comparing yourself
to people who are worth 200 500 a
billion and that never ends never ever
ends the point I always make is like the
the minimum wage in um in the MLB is
like 500,000 a year whatever it is 400
what what whatever it is a shitload of
money by any definition if you're making
half a million dollars a year and I
guarantee you there's not a single
minimum wage professional baseball
player who thinks they're doing well
because they're comparing themselves to
their teammates who are making 10
million a year and so there's no end to
that but you always think there is which
is why I for myself had this idea once
my net worth is X I'm never going to
work ever again but once now that I'm
here maybe it is because I'm comparing
myself to other people other authors
maybe that's at least part of it so I
think even if I can write these
philosophies and made a Liv in talking
about these like I'm still susceptible
to that as as anyone else I think
everybody is so I think it's such a
natural thing I mean in all of evolution
what matters is not how much success you
have it matters that you have more
success than the other person because in
a competition for resources that's all
that matters doesn't matter if you're
worth a billion dollars if somebody else
is worth a billion in one they have more
resources in you and from an
evolutionary perspective they're going
to win and you're going to lose so that
like always chasing no matter how much
you have is is a big psychological
underpinning to people's anxiety the
second that I would mention that's
that's probably equally as important is
realizing that there is not one right
answer for everybody and everyone in
finance is always sing is seeking the
right answer like quote unquote the
right it doesn't exist I think it's much
closer to like your taste in music of
like there's no such thing as the best
music you like this I like that to each
their own and a lot of times when you
have a financial debate of people are
like I can't believe manage your money
like that why don't you do it like me
you're not actually debating it's people
with a different risk tolerance
different social aspirations different
family Dynamics who are talking over
each other and I think it's like it's
hard for people to come to terms of like
look that works for you this works for
me to each our own people don't want to
settle on that because it's easier to
think that there should be a right
answer like there is in math you uh you
had this quote I think it was from the
book but it could have been from the a
blog post that he wrote where he said
the biggest risk and important news
story of the next 10 years will be
something nobody is talking about today
and but you're in this weird position
where you work at a VC where you
actually do have to predict the future a
bit or at least you're around people who
are trying to predict the future what do
you think are there any Trends or topics
today that you think in 10 years are
going to be a lot more common and
popular well the good the good news for
me is that since I'm not involved in the
the deal side of the VC that it doesn't
really rest on my shoulders to make
those predictions of the risk that we
know of which is like obviously very
distinct from the surprises that are
going to be more important but of the
risk that we know of i' I've been saying
for years that the biggest um by far in
the global economy is is demographics
the terrible demographics that almost
the entire industrialized world has
outside of India and Africa almost the
entire world is shrinking population
wise and the based economies China Japan
all of Europe are are shrinking very
very fast China's working age population
age 16 to 64 will decline by 200 million
people between now and 2050 it's just
like there's no precedent outside of
like the black death plague there's no
precedent for that in all of human
history it's always been the case that
economic growth was driven by the fact
that there was massive population uh
growth and we just don't have it anymore
and in the United States we have about
the best demographics relative to our
peers but it's still way less than we've
had for the last years and all economic
growth is either population growth or
productivity growth all economic growth
comes from those two things and so when
you take half the equation of economic
growth and for the last 100 years it's
been really good and now it's at best
poor if not a headwind it's a very
different world totally different world
and maybe like the takeaway from that is
it used to be that 4% economic growth
was like oh good you're running at full
capacity now maybe it's 2% just because
we've taken away so much of that so of
the of the things that we know are going
to be a risk that's probably the most
prominent can you explain that one a
little more I've heard Elon talk about
this too that like uh you know the big
risk is that we're not having enough
babies and at first I thought he was
just saying it to cover his ass because
he was like you know knocking everyone
up but then I no no he's serious about
this he actually believes this to be
true uh but I don't fully get it uh I'm
maybe just kind of dumb about this so
maybe just explain like I'm a I'm a
5-year-old so uh if economic growth goes
down but the population shrinks is it
kind of like isn't there kind of like a
per capita type of thing where it's like
yes what's the big deal like why why is
that disastrous if uh if economic
productivity slows down if there's also
less less people to Shar you the pie
shrinks but there's less people eating
pie um does that matter or is that the
wrong way to think about it why is it I
think it's it's not the wrong way to
think about it because you could look at
Japan for the last 30 years which Japan
for the last 30 years has had abysmal
demographics but I think it's safe to
say that by and large it's been a fairly
Pleasant place to live it does not led
to economic collapse but their their
their their version of an index has been
[__] yeah from a money perspective yes
that's a slightly different topic
because the reason it's been [__] is
because it was so preposterously
overvalued in 1990 got it um so that's
like the two two separate different
stories but by and large it has not led
to economic collapse the one thing I
would say though is like what it does
lead to is when you don't have a growing
economy you have much less investment
you're not investing in new businesses
new homes new factories because you
don't need them you're fine with what
you have whenever you have less
investment you have less Innovation and
so in those situations like when was the
last incredible tech company to come out
of Japan I I I'm sure I'm sure one or
two exist but I can't name it off the
top of my head versus if you if if you
and I were talking in 1990 and we said
what was the last tech company we'd be
like oh my gosh Sony Toshiba going like
mitsub going down the list they're
everywhere because when Japan had a
booming population it was investment up
the yinyang of like new technologies and
so when you once you remove that from
the equation you can still have a
pleasant Society that's in some form of
stasis but you're not going to have
growth not just economic growth but
techn technology growth Medical
Technology growth like all the things
that we associate with like a better
life kind of grows out the window so
maybe is the case that for a lot of the
developed world over the next 50 years
it's still a pleasant place to live but
the idea of like every generation is
going to live 30% better than their
parents like that idea might kind of go
out the window uh Sam just asked you
about like Trends or prediction like
what what what is going to come in the
future but actually your your new book
is actually about the opposite it's
about what's not going to change same as
ever right so y can you explain the
premise of the book I like the buffet
story that you kind of lead with maybe
start with that one but uh give us the
the teaser of like what are some of the
the like I buy the premise that some
things don't change um what are some of
the big Sil whats that come out of that
but start with the Buffett story yeah so
I had lunch last summer maybe two
summers ago with a guy who is very close
friends with Warren Buffett and uh this
guy was driving around with Buffett in
2009 in Buffett's car in Omaha they're
just driving around town together in
2009 the economy was a wreck and there's
like businesses boarded up and it was
like the economic apocalypse and this
guy says Warren like how do we ever
recover from this like how how's the
world ever going to be the same and
Warren said do you know what the best
selling candy bar was in
1962 gu said no Warren Buffett Warren
says Snickers and Buffett says you know
what the best selling candy bar is today
guy says no he says Snickers and that's
that's the end of the story the premise
being like don't worry about like how
are we going to change like find
something that does not change and bet
on that and I've often thought I've been
a a financial writer for 17 years and
it's always bothered me how bad the
whole industry is at predicting the next
bar Market the next recession the next
pandemic the next technology nobody's
any good at it that's like a little bit
too harsh but that's that's
directionally true nobody's any good at
it and so there's two things you can do
with that one you could become more of a
cynic and just say nobody knows anything
don't even try or kind of the buffet
approach of like find something that is
never going to change and put your
weight on that and so that was one
observation the other was as a student
of History realizing when you're reading
about the economy from a hundred years
ago or 500 years ago or a thousand years
ago there's some things that you read
about and you're like oh things were
very different back then but there are
even more things that you can read that
make you stop and think that's exactly
how it is today the way that people
responded to Greed and fear and risk and
uncertainty is the exact same today as
it was a 100 years ago and so putting
those two things together if you can
find things of human behavior that are
never going to change then you know
something that is going to be part of
your future so stop pretending that you
know when the next recession is going to
happen but study how people respond to
recessions when they do happen because
that's never changeed so it's going to
be part of our future and so that's kind
of the premise of the book it's just a
bunch of little stories of things that
facets of human behavior that have
always been with us and I think always
will be and you like regardless of what
is going to happen in our future you
know that these little bits of behavior
are going to be a part of it and so
what's something where when you studied
how people let's say respond to Greed or
fear or change or whatever and you
looked at these patterns of human
behavior what's something that you like
the best research or books or insights
that I get I'm like oh I feel like I
have a superpower like you know almost
like I could read people's minds now
right so it sounds like by studying what
doesn't change or how how human behavior
Works did you come out with anything
that you're like did you change anything
that you do or did you have a new
strategy or a new plan or any new like
um could you action that uh cuz I you
know I guess my my skeptical view would
be I feel like I could understand how
people behaved in the past but attaching
that to what the hell am I supposed to
do today is is not so easy of a leap
what's one that you made yourself doing
this I know this is an answer that
people will find inadequate but to me
it's it's incredibly powerful and
important and I think the main plea in
the book is for humility it's not even
about the the examples that of things
that are never going to change that's
obviously the core of the book but the
reason we're doing that is because we
have humility and not fooling ourselves
to thinking that we know what's going to
change what are the three biggest
economic stories of our adult lives by
far by an order of magnitude it's
September 11th Leeman Brothers
collapsing and covid like by an order of
magnitude Nothing Else Matters more than
those three things and the common
denominator is nobody saw them coming
they're not in any economic Outlook no
analyst forecast unless you were had
inside information you were part of
those things nobody saw them coming and
it's always been like that because you
can go back another generation and it
was Pearl Harbor collapse of the Soviet
Union all these things that even if in
hindsight you're like oh you you should
have seen those coming Great Depression
of course the fact is that very few
people did if anybody and something like
Pearl Harbor you could not have seen it
coming but think about how that changed
the entire fabric of society not just
the economy but everything and going
forward it will be like that too you can
state with so much certainty that the
biggest economic story of our lifetimes
in the future or or even the next 12
months is something that you and I are
not talking about today I mean what
what's the biggest global news story of
2023 this is this is subjective but I
would say it's Israel Hamas which is
something that even if you were an
expert in Middle East politics you did
not see coming on October 6 to let alone
people like us so that's and I think
it's it's always been like that it'll be
like that next year and the reason that
we that view like we we tend to ignore
that is because I think coming to terms
with it is too painful coming to terms
with the AA and admitting to yourself
that we don't know what's going to
happen next is a really uncomfortable
level of uncertainty it's much easier
and more comfortable to just say to
pretend that we do which is why the
market for punditry is always going to
exist no matter how poor the results are
and so I think that's the biggest
actionable takeaway for me is I I I
don't forecast I I think I think it's
much healthier to read more history and
fewer forecasts and when you read
history you start focusing on the
indelible behaviors that never change
and you become more humble in your
ability to fool yourself into thinking
that we do know is what is going to
change Morgan I know you got to leave
you got have a hard stop in two minutes
so let me I want to ask a a very
takeaway or in actionable question which
is what two or three or four however
many want history books can I go and
read over the next month that do the
best job of me not not a book like yours
that Aggregates a bunch of them but
literally a specific era or a specific
book that I can go and read that does a
good job of of showing this where I'll
read it and I'll be like oh this is
exactly what I'm experiencing now or
things won't change I think one of the
best World War II books because it's not
only a book about the military
operations but also the human element on
the ground is Eric larsson's book The
Splendid in the vial which is a pretty
recent book I think it came out four
years ago and it's about the London
Blitz bombing in World War II Eric
Larsson I think is the greatest living
Storyteller period and he's so good his
book on the Lucitania is wonderful it's
absolutely epic so so that book is is is
incredible Doris Kern's Goodwin's book
no ordinary time which is about how FDR
managed World War II it's not about the
war itself it's about how he managed the
politics and the emotions of it is
absolutely stunning I also use that book
as an example of I think the book is 700
pages and every single word needs to be
there there's not a single wasted word
in the 700 Pages it's she's just like
such an extraordinary writer those are
two that really stick out as like some
of the best and you're doing an
excellent job of giving Into The
Stereotype of 30 or 40 something year
old white guys obsessing over World War
II what we're supposed to do yeah
everyone talks about the Roman Empire
[__] the Roman Empire World War II
that's where it's at
man it's it's so true I I Can't Get
Enough it I will say the last thing I
say because I do have to jump I I I
think the reason World War II is so
interesting is because it was the most
documented major event and therefore
like the emotion the emotions on either
end of the spectrum from despair to
Elation are there's more documented
examples of that during that six-year
period than have ever existed in all of
human history so it's not just
understanding the military and the
politics it's like if you want to
understand human emotions there's no
better Spotlight or magnifying glass
than studying World War II well we
appreciate you coming on man this is
awesome um we're big fans of your first
book I I know I'm in the middle of
reading the second one same as ever and
uh you're badass we appreciate you doing
this thanks guys this has been fun
thanks Morgan all right that's the pod
[Music]